welcome back
American Beauty is the story of a man
who longed to have an affair with a high
school girl which is not to be confused
with American Pie in which a high school
boy has an affair with the dessert
if I did that movie look what you did to
the kogo and here are three young stars
of American Beauty ladies and gentlemen
please welcome West Bentley mena Suvari
and Thora Birch
Ricky Fitts the character I play in
American Beauty spends a lot of his time
looking through a camera he films
everything dead birds plastic bags and
Jane the girl next door
in other words Ricky will someday make
an amazing documentary Short subject
until he does here are the nominees for
Best Documentary Short subject I witness
Bert van Bork came again Susan Hannah
hidari and William a white fur
the wildest show in the South Angola
prison rodeo simian sofa and Jonathan
stack
and the Oscar goes to Suzanne Hannah
hidari and William a white bird for
Kingdom Susanna Hannah Hager a and
William a white bird documented the life
of artist Dan Kaplan der who wrote and
narrated his own story this is the first
Oscar for mcgary and white folk
we have followed down Keplinger for 45
45 years for 13 years 13 years an
amazing spirit in a body that society
may not have included but tonight he is
included and he's honored as an artist
and we thank the Academy and for giving
him this honor and we thank Sheila
Nevins at HBO for transforming the world
of documentaries and for nurturing us
and giving us wings and in exchange we
give her King [ __ ]
we thank the University of Maryland
where we work we think Nancy walzog and
HBO my friends and family I'm here
because of you tonight as possible and
Dance Spirit that touches us all in his
writing his art and inspired Michael
Bacon's music and the sensitive Edington
of Jeff Bart's a Baltimore crew and
loved assessee baby Wow
she was Oscar nominated for her
heart-stopping performance in pulp
fiction and he is a noted actor and
novelist please welcome
uma Thurman and Ethan Hawke
sports music and politics are the
subjects of this year's nominated
documentary features they're all
remarkable and gripping films made
without the use of a single actor don't
give them any ideas the nominees are
Ganga's booze Muirfield Village an
18-gauge on the ropes Nanette Burstein
and Breton waters one day in September
Arthur Cohen and Kevin Macdonald
speaking in strings how the florium and
Lily Beck Foster the Oscar goes to one
day in September are pecan and Kevin
Macdonald this is the third Oscar in
this category for Arthur Cohen and the
first nomination for Kevin Macdonald
your friends at the academy first of all
I would like to say that this Oscar goes
to the terrific team which made one day
in September headed by Kevin Macdonald
John bad sick interesting right Linnea
Birnbaum and above all last not least
Michael Douglas I want you to know that
in contrast to all the films you're
honoring tonight this film which took
two years and four months in the making
was only completed in October
consequently the film one day in
September and be Reese released anywhere
in the world and as a result with this
Oscar you members of the Academy have
given a terrific sign to members of all
the world if the filmmakers that the
Academy in its judgment is not basing
itself at all and is not influenced by
books of his success but it is topping
and insisting only on the outstanding
quality of a film which can be
remembered for a long time thank you so
much for this